hallo mein name ist programm herzlich
willkommen ja heute zu einem neuen video
erzählt bereiten sie wieder eingeblendet
wir machen heute einen pizza käse pizza
ist und zwar einer seite haben wir eine
sehr günstige filtern auf der anderen
seite eine sehr teure bezahlt und dann
schauen wir ob ich daran ein unterschied
der strecke bis heute für einen
supermarkt gegangen hier in meiner nähe
wo wir eine pizza gekauft und das heißt
hier mal ganz kurz die einwendungen wir
sind in einem supermarkt freunde bei dem
ich denke dass sie relativ günstige
pitzl im angebot haben das heißt wir
bewegen uns jetzt mal in die tiefkühl ab
32 euro 300 das ist relativ günstig und
unter einen euro pro pizza beraten
ich meine damen und herren die für die
marke zeigen
das war die günstigste pizza die es dort
gab diese pizza kostete 1 99 und das
sind drei pizzen drin das heißt eine 190
durch 303 so günstig war wie diese pizza
werden jetzt auf jeden fall vergleichen
mit einer pizza die ich mir jetzt bei
für dollar bestellen werde ich befinde
mich jetzt die gerade auf hudora und
schaue jetzt hier gerade was ist das
hier eigentlich viele adressen
wir haben jetzt ein pizza restaurant
gefunden ich bietet dort kochen deine
pizza margherita 13 49 also absichtlich
der liefern gebühr 11 eur 50 das heißt
vergleichen heute eine was ist 21 ich
gucke etwas 190 durch 30 wendy angelegt
habe dann wisst ihr noch dass hier
bereits mittendrin waren und es floss
der 19
ein euro 99 durch drei sind 66 cent so
eine pizza hierin ich mag das jetzt mal
einfach aus damit ihr mal genau so etwas
das sie für eine pizza ist und zwar
schon hier sind drei spitzen drin und
eine davon denn heute essen das heißt 66
cent haben wir rufen nicht ausmachen
bisher war diese 66 cent mit sarah wird
jetzt verglichen mit einer 11 eur 50
margherita abbas jetzt die bands sehr
gut 11 eur 50
ich habe schnell und wir waren ja ich
zeige etwas von beispielsweise vor dass
machen kann eben mal auf ein essen war
das weiß welche vorteile sehen wir schon
ein schock eingebettete sie schon
schöner shops ist der minister von de
hier gab es viele verschiedene produkte
werden hier goodies wetter haben
t-shirts socken wir haben auch mein buch
hier drin des buches mit eines der
besten bücher was wirklich je gemacht
wurde wenn nicht sogar das beste und ich
meine damen und herren ich habe da
wirklich gar kein geld gespart sondern
hat mir direkt 20 stück selber gekauft
deswegen bin ich bestseller mit dem buch
weil ich die alle gekauft hat man kann
das buch beispielsweise auf die besser
lesen wenn man einfach 20 stück am start
hatte sich auf super als bettdecke
[Musik]
es ist ein absolutes lieblingsbuch
okay wir als nächstes danke dir nein
wollten dass wir jetzt die pizza haben
aber die haben noch gar nicht offen
gepackt haben wir leben jetzt auf jeden
fall unsere 66 cent sachen packen jetzt
mal im vorgeheizten ofen
über die pizza hier drin haben jetzt mal
dass diese konstanz kamerafrau wow das
war super ich möchte meine
besteckschublade meine jahre und damit
wir uns jetzt nicht verbreitet und zwar
ohne diese dann rausfallen weil er daran
ergibt
die pfizer seit herbst die seinerseits
nach dem ofen hieraus wir ihn
ausschalten ja und wir öffnen den karton
dem karton
der pc wird sein sind hier die spitze
aus supermarkt für 66 cent und dann
haben wir vorne die pizza für 11 eur 50
die wir uns gerade bestellt haben ich
stehe jetzt im vordergrund setze ein
stück ab und dieses stück werde ich
jetzt nicht die rede auf den teller
packen und von den linken
okay was heißt bild von den günstigen
pizza weil ich eh nicht jedenfalls ein
stück land das ich meine damen und
herren wir haben jetzt über offene damen
und herren wir haben nun hier das
günstige stück und hier das stück fast
10 mehr als zehnmal so teuer ist als das
andere das heißt ich werde die beiden
jetzt vergleichen
ich probiere zuerst einmal die günstige
pizzeria 60 cent aus dem supermarkt
guten muss man sagen wenn ich ein
restaurant so eine pizza bekommen würde
würde ich sagen na ja wenn ich jetzt
vielleicht nicht nur mal hingehen aber
dafür dass sie wirklich und das muss man
ja immer im hinterkopf halten 66 cent
kostet das ist es was ist mega gut
jetzt probieren wir hier die andere
flitzer gibt wirklich aussieht wie sie
die echten käse verabschiede sich gerade
wir haben übrigens auch extra
büffelmozzarella drauf verdammt noch mal
extra mozzarella darauf war probiert
erstmal allein hier nur den käse und der
käse schmeckt viel geiler als auf der
pizza selbst schon krass im käse gebe
ich eine 10 15 aber das gesamtpaket muss
natürlich überzeugung deswegen h
man schmeckt ganz klar dass diese pizza
aus dem restaurant kommt und von leuten
die wirklich ahnung haben wir hier ist
der käse schmecken mega mega geil aber
es ist halt nicht so war kennt die
pizzas natürlich auch stellt sich seit
schon halbe stunde alle die ihr schmeckt
einfach viel costa und die hier ist ja
jetzt halt über wenn man die verhält ist
halt einfach übel riecht wieder ein
waschlappen wir solchen fazit ziehen
können parallel laufen experte sagt
richtig gestellt haben eben ein ganzes
schiff versorgt ich liebe pizza alles
und ich muss wirklich sagen das mir
diese pizza besser schmeckt als liebe
hier aber ist natürlich auch kapiert wie
hält 50 bezahlt natürlich die setzen
bisschen teil und müssen lambrecht steht
ja auch schon 40 minuten diese hier ist
jetzt mehr oder weniger frisch also
werden jetzt gerade erst ein backofen
getan
die ist doch affig dies noch warm aber
ich muss wirklich sagen ich hätte
wirklich gedacht hat wie ein supermarkt
ganz unterwartet pizarro 71 66 cent
gekostet hat dass die total bescheuert
ist ist die aber nicht geht echt klar
beschuldigt auch probieren bei der du
willst die besser da wird ordentlich
gemacht
dafür wird aber auf jeden fall
verschiedene meine damen und herren ich
hab mir heute schmeckt man wirklich eine
riesen unterschied zwischen einer
finanziell sehr günstigen supermarkt mit
von einer pizza die man sich online
bestellt für über zehn euro kann man
schmeckt ein
steiner hatte bei der frische da ist
nämlich wirklich die pizza mit dem
backofen machen dafür ich mal noch ein
bisschen wärmer ist ein kräftiger und so
weiter allerdings andererseits ist bei
der restaurant nizza da merkt man da
sind ganz viele hochwertige zutaten
drauf gepackt worden davon sollte sich
allerdings auch vom chefkoch schlechthin
[Musik]
wenn es euch gefallen hat lässt auch
gerne